is it ever okay to violate core values
to achieve a goal okay so first of all
really obvious your values and your
goals should be aligned they should not
be adversarial they shouldn't be
countered to each other and if you think
about what your goals are your goals
should be set up in a way that they
support your values
and vice versa that's just the way it is
so I'm not sure where this is gonna be
an issue if you're setting up goals that
are contrary to your values you've got
some issues now I guess if you had the
goal of winning the blue belt jiu-jitsu
championships and in order to win you
you cheated like you claimed someone was
reaping your leg and use it on you tap
and you get the guide to qualified and
you win that's could be an example right
now do I support that no you know that's
wrong you you don't win against the
values of actually the values of martial
arts to do that so you didn't win
anything and you didn't achieve your
goal because you weren't actually the
best so I say no on that one uh another
one let's say you wanted to make a
certain level of profit at your company
so you cheated a little bit on the
quality of the manufacturing and you
sold items that weren't quite reliable
do I support that no right for animal
and why let me tell you why because your
goal your goal is not even aligned with
your goal itself because when you start
making substandard manufactured items
what's gonna happen in the long run
people gonna say we don't like these
yeah we're not gonna buy them anymore so
you didn't win you might have wanted the
short term but you didn't win and and
again you're going against your value
you should have values that you don't
want to you know take profit over making
good product and again in the long run
that values gonna cost you right people
aren't gonna want to buy your product
anymore okay another one I could think
of like let's say your goal was to lose
weight or to gain weight or whatever
some kind of positive physical change
and so you're working on it but then you
decide you're gonna jump on the steroids
right you're gonna jump on steroids
and and you get that goal right because
steroids are a huge advantage but again
I say no because if you think about what
your goal is like why are you trying to
gain weight or lose weight your goal is
to be is to be healthy right that's your
value as you value your health
mm-hm and so when the minute you start
doing something that's counter to your
health well that's not that's not
helping your long-term it's that your
value is not allowing with your goal and
your goal is not aligned with your value
so get them lined up mm-hmm
so now might we at some point compromise
our values compromise our values to
reach a goal I think that changes the
answer a little bit right we might
compromise remember that question that
we had about the people that are snakes
and how do you work with them hey you
know should you work with someone that's
dishonest or backstabbing but they're a
cog in the machine of your team and your
values right they might be to call a
person out and say yeah you're a you're
a backstabber and I don't want to work
with you that that might be what your
values tell you to do but your goal and
if you do that you first of all you
don't progress you don't your team
doesn't work better together they work
worse together and so in the long run
you don't win because you stuck hardcore
with your values and by the way if you
stick with your if you if you bend your
values you compromise your values a
little bit to get through this
transitional period now you get promoted
now you get in a situation where you can
fire that person that's a backstabber
mmm so you you have to compromise your
values as a person a little bit and you
know there's the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
right the enemy of my enemy is my friend
so you might compromise your values
short-term working somebody that you're
not totally aligned with value eyes and
again if you're gonna get the long-term
strategic goal well then maybe it's
worth it because gonna put you in a
position where you can then hold your
values better
Efram um from a senior position er from
a more
full position so you might compromise
them a little bit again these are small
compromises and you should have things
of course we got things that values that
you're you never gonna compromise on
right hitting a girl Yeah right
you should you should never hit a girl
right never hit a woman now that being
said if there's a woman that's about to
do something truly evil look you know
kill a child or some kind of a terrorist
act and the only thing you have that you
can stop it is the hitter will guess
what she's getting hit you know what I
mean so even then your value of never
hitting a girl can be compromised
momentarily while you stop a child from
being murdered or whatever yeah you know
we as we hold a value we always want to
tell the truth hmm
but if you had a an extreme example if
you had some kind of a state secret and
and you got captured of course you might
lie about that and there's little I mean
we could get into a whole like white lie
discussion on stuff like when your wife
asks you how's the chicken and you want
to tell it it's the most dry in in
charcoal tasting item that you've ever
put your mouth that's not gonna help you
long-term no so I might I might
compromise my values of being truthful
and tell her it's pretty good can I have
some more ketchup over here can I get
some more barbecue sauce on this ketchup
on chicken in Oakland and I'm gonna go
grab some more water would you like so I
might compromise my values a little bit
there so I guess what I'm saying is and
people this is the thing people probably
what they think of my persona because
people will think oh I was gonna be this
uncompromising never settle all how no
slack kind of person right that's what
people want it want you don't want
I guess want to see me ass but the
reality is
reason right reason and thought can can
override values for the right reasons
and that's why we can think there that's
why we can thinking there's there's
actually times there's actually times
when holding your values goes against
your values so if you always back up
your friends right you always back up
your friends but then your friend does
something that's totally immoral and is
against your values well then you can't
back up you can't hold the value of
backing up your friends because guess
what they did something immoral they did
something that was wrong and so if you
held your values you'd be not holding
your values
that's the dichotomy there right that's
the dichotomy that and the additional
dichotomy is you hold your values right
you hold those basic principles that you
believe in but at the same time you've
got to apply logic and reason to them to
make sure that they are supporting your
long-term goal and your long-term values
mmm cuz you don't want to you don't want
to make a hard stand on something that
costs you everything we're now in the
future you can no longer manipulate any
more situations that's one of the things
that makes leadership a handle and life
hard mmm is that it is in black and
white it is in black mind it's grey and
so our decisions on these very things
these are the challenges of leadership
and there's there's no way right or
wrong answer of saying if it's right or
wrong to violate your your values to
achieve a goal that initial question
there's too many variables in that
there's too many variables but start
with this part that I started the whole
answer with align your values with your
goal that's where you start and then you
use reason and logic and fought to
determine your actions based on the
situation weighed against your values
you have to think
so given what you're saying yes it's so
what's less like just values like you
have a dinner plate with here's my
values kind of thing it's more of a
hierarchy of values so you will violate
your values if it's on you know level
two or a level four yeah like I'll hit
I'll knock a girl right out if it's in
the way of my higher value witches
protect your family protecting my family
kids you know all this stuff
same thing with girls don't mask ladies
out there don't mess with that goes
family up coming at you you know
obviously same thing with the you know
it's writing and you're backing up your
friend yeah my values back into my
friend that's level two you know the
whole ear morale thing
assaulting a girl I don't know whatever
that you know yeah that's level four so
sorry number two you know I'm going for
number four cannon so it's like a
hierarchy yeah you got a little
hierarchy values now there's some you
know obviously there's some that I can't
you know you could give any of one of
your highest values that you could come
up with and you could sit here and and
theoretically come up with a situation
where you would sacrifice that value
yeah yeah so that's why we're humans we
have the ability to think we have the
ability reason and sometimes you might
have to compromise your values a little
bit to fill survive I or one right yeah
to survive and get so that you can long
term carry out your values to a higher
degree yeah yeah like the and the back
to the people want to lose weight you
know yeah if usually people who I don't
know I guess I would imagine that
usually people who take steroids their
value isn't the health it's like because
people typically unless it's a medical
thing you know it's a good point um you
know the story thing for al it's for to
win or did but be cool yeah which is
kind of straight but you know it's
usually to win a come but um but
nonetheless I think that holds true give
you know he said and I think it's kind
of kind of coming together there I think
that it is like a hierarchy
yeah yeah and if someone's gonna use
steroids to cheat that's I mean even
that we it's a whole nother discussion
yeah but what are they really proving
what are they really winning right yeah
and that goes back to remember I forget
what we were talking about like some
people like they want to they want to
they want
appear to win you know especially now
you can see it on like online you don't
spend that much time I'd like to put
this cruising Facebook but you see you
can see someone that you know I don't
know they're there they're about to
murder each other husband and wife they
hate each other they don't even sleep in
the same room but they went on vacation
with their kids or whatever and they're
like oh so and love in front of the
ferris wheel or the waterfall or
whatever and you're like you just want
people to think you win you just want to
appear that you won you know but it's
not real that's why people cheat yeah
that's why I like the guy that you jitsu
thing when they're like okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna say this guy reach my leg I'm
gonna tap all he's DQ you can't do that
but you know you cheated kind of thing
his goal wasn't to win it was just to
get the medal mm-hm so they it's you
know well his goal is Dan here but he's
just he doesn't have the proper values
actually be the winner he needs to check
his values he needs to check his
hierarchy of values